madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal la viande de john kennedy le
fils du président assassiné portées
disparues les recherches se poursuivent
activement au large de longue haleine
toujours aucune trace de l'appareil
piloté par celui que l'amérique connaît
sous le nom de john jeune à son bord son
épouse et quelques amis trois ans après
l'explosion en vol d'un boeing de l'alte
w à un document révèle que le
constructeur connaissait la dangerosité
des réservoirs mais des modifications
aurait été trop coûteuse tour de france
après l'abandon hier de christophe
bassons celui qui symbolise le monsieur
propre du cyclisme a décidé aujourd'hui
de s'expliquer l'hiver en plein été avec
le coup d'envoi des défilés de la haute
couture sur le podium aujourd'hui les
modèles de torrents de classicisme et
raffinement
je vous propose de vraies ce journal
avec cette nouvelle qui nous est
parvenue en début d'après-midi le fils
du président assassiné john kennedy est
porté disparu l'avion qu'il pilotait se
serait abîmé la nuit dernière au large
des côtes de langue island à son bord
les pousses de celui que l'on avait
baptisé john john et quelques amis les
recherches sont en cours le président
clinton pour sa part se tient
régulièrement informé mars et rires
c'était il ya quelques semaines celui qu
un grand magazine américain qualifié
d'homme le plus séduisant du monde john
kennedy junior sortaient des locaux du
journal grand public job qu'il avait
fondée à new york
son avion a disparu dans cette zone de
l'océan atlantique au large de l'île new
yorkaise de langue island au nord-est
des etats-unis en compagnie de son
épouse caroline et d'une autre personne
il se rendait dans la résidence d'été de
la famille au mariage de sa cousine rory
la plus jeune fille de son oncle
assassiné robert kennedy
l'avion un monomoteur piper saratoga du
même type que celui ci avait décollé
hier soir à 20h38 2h38 ce matin heure
française dans aéroports du new jersey
près de new york
il devait atterrir à 6 heures heure
française
dans l'île de martha's vineyard il n'y
est jamais parvenu
john kennedy avait passé son brevet de
pilote l'an dernier et il était
peut-être aux commandes de l'appareil au
moment du décollage
la météo était favorable mais la
visibilité était sans doute mauvaises en
raison de forte brume de chaleur
des centaines d'hommes plus d'une
vingtaine d'avions participent aux
recherches dirigées par l'armée de l'air
américaine une vedette et un hélicoptère
des gardes-côtes tente de retrouver une
balise d'avion qui aurait émis des
signaux ce matin et il aurait aperçu sur
la zone des débris qui pourraient être
les restes de l'accord disparu toutes
les stars de la télévision américaine
sont sur le pont chaque chaîne diffuse
minute par minute des nouvelles des
recherches l'amérique toute entière
partage en direct l'émotion provoquée
par ce nouveau coup du sort qui frappe
la famille kennedy
je pense que c'est une tragédie pour la
famille et aussi pour tous les
américains
quant à malheur arrive à une famille
aussi importante ça devient la ferme
tous à l'heure qu'il est on ne sait
toujours pas dans quelles circonstances
exactes aura disparu celui qui fut le
chouchou des américains et que l'on voit
ici filmée une dernière fois jeudi
dernier au cours d'un match de baseball
et puis ces deux informations qui nous
parviennent à l'instant des débris
supposé de l'avion disparu aurait été
retrouvé par des garde-côtes
c'est une première information la
seconde ne semble expliquer que l'avion
se trouvait à 16 kilomètres de
l'aéroport lorsque les radars ont établi
qu'il a piqué passes en 12 secondes
d'une altitude de 800 à 400 m c'est du
moins ce qu'indique ce qu'indique la
chaîne américaine nbc évidemment si nous
avons d'autres explications d'autres
informations nous y reviendrons
la malédiction des kennedy avec donc ce
nouveau drame qui frappe la famille une
série de tragédies on se rappellera bien
sûr de l'assassinât de john fitzgerald
et de son frère robert et puis tout
récemment c'est le cousin michael qui se
tué dans un accident de ski john kennedy
dont l'image reste gravé dans les
esprits
saluant le cercueil de son père au
cimetière d'arlington était devenu aux
etats-unis le symbole de la réussite et
de la séduction philippe rochot de john
kennedy junior l'histoire gardera
l'image de ce petit garçon de 3 ans à
qui la mère jackie kennedy demande de
saluer la dépouille du père le président
john fitzgerald kennedy assassiné
c'était en 1963 sur le chemin du
cimetière d'arlington et le début de ce
que le monde allait appeler la tragédie
des kennedy
le petit john présenté comme l'enfant
d'une famille heureuse et unie allait
être le témoin de ces drames
cinq ans plus tard en 68 7 et robert qui
les vit ici à gauche le frère de john
fitzgerald kennedy qui allait lui aussi
être assassiné un an avant que edward
kennedy lui ne se tue en voiture
et pourtant john john né en 60 était
promis au plus bel avenir avec un père
et une mère dont la jeunesse et la
popularité faisait les héros de cette
nouvelle amérique embourbé déjà dans la
guerre du vietnam et qui voulaient se
reconnaître dans la famille
présidentielle
peu de kennedy auront finalement mener
jusqu'au bout leur carrière politique
john john avait pourtant penser toucher
au bonheur quand il s'est marié avec
carolyn bessette
mais il a dû suivre encore le cortège
des défunts du clan kennedy rose la
grand mère celle qui dit on donne à ses
fils et petit-fils les clés de la
réussite ou jacky la mer dont la vie
privée alimenta jusqu'au bout les
commentaires et prolonger les drames et
les coups de théâtre au sein du clan
kennedy ou encore michael kennedy son
cousin décédé dans un accident de ski il
y a un an
sans oublier david kennedy mort d'une
overdose en 84 john-john une nouvelle
fois l'occasion de se pencher sur la
tombe du père à l'occasion de la mort de
sa mère jackie et d'émouvoir encore
l'amérique
et pourtant ce john john que dès
l'enfance sa famille a tenté de protéger
des regards de la presse a cru trouver
sa voie dans la création d'un magazine
politique georges pour le grand public
ce qu'il a mis à son tour sous les
projecteurs et les flashs des paparazzis
son passé son histoire ses 38 ans lui
ont valu le surnom de l'homme le plus
sexy du monde alors qu'il était dit on
le plus sage du clan kennedy
on lui prête plus d'une aventure
féminine john jeune acteur de théâtre
avocat manqué directeur de publication a
tout fait pour être autre chose que ce
petit garçon saluant le cercueil de son
père est adorée des américains il n'aura
pas vraiment réussi à changer ce
personnage qui lui collait à la peau et
nous rejoignent et en direct des états
unis à cap canaveral d'où partira dans
48 heures la navette américaine
dominique derda vous êtes donc au centre
spatial kennedy
on imagine l'émotion et l'inquiétude de
la mairie quelles sont les dernières
informations qui nous sont parvenues
écoutez l'émotion et l'inquiétude
d'abord comme vous l'imaginez
effectivement sont très forte ici dans
ce centre spatial qui porte le nom de
son père dès que la nouvelle a été
connue ce matin la plupart des chaînes
de radio et télévision ont interrompu
leurs programmes pour diffuser les
dernières nouvelles les dernières
nouvelles que nous connaissions tiennent
en prêtant peu de mon arrêt après il y
aquelques on a appris il ya quelques
minutes que l'on aurait retrouvé une
valise à une trentaine de kilomètres de
l'île de martha's vineyard qui était la
destination de l'appareil
une valise qui porterait le nom de paix
cette paix set c'était le nom de jeune
fille de l'épousé de john jeune et
c'était aussi le nom de jeune fille de
sa belle soeur la soeur de la soeur de
sa femme un canular ce matin a fait
croire à eau à des chaînes de radio et
télévision américaine que l'on avait
retrouvé une route du train
d'atterrissage de l'appareil ou en tout
cas d'un appareil d'un type identiques à
ce petit piper saratoga que pilotait
john john kennedy
l'information s'est révélée fausse les
eaux la zone de recherche pour l'instant
est en train de se resserrer comme je
vous le disais une trentaine de
kilomètres de l'île de martha's vineyard
là où l'avion rey aurait disparu une
vingtaine de minutes avant l'heure de
son arrivée c'est ted kennedy le
sénateur l'oncle de john john qui
coordonnerait l'ensemble des recherches
si tu savais qu'il ya différentes
agences de recherche amer
cannes ce temps les garde-côtes que les
forces aériennes qui cherchent en mer le
long des côtes et aussi sur terre pour
essayer de retrouver des traces de
l'appareil on a entendu ce matin le
signal d'une balise de détresse mais ce
signal très vite social très vite se
serait éteint voilà tout ce que l'on
sait de fiable pour l'instant c'est pas
grand chose près d'une quinzaine
d'heures après que l'appareil ait
disparu des radars
la famille a annoncé ce matin après
s'être retrouvée dans une église pour
prier
la famille a annoncé que le mariage
auquel devait assister john-john venait
d'être annulée et reportée à une date
ultérieure
merci dominique derda de ces précisions
j'ajoute que le porte parole de la
famille pourrait prendre la parole dans
les minutes qui viennent bien entendu
nous transmettrons cette intervention
tom bishop bonsoir vous êtes
universitaires américains vous êtes
directeur du centre d'études français à
new york
pour quelles raisons la disparition
possible probable de john kennedy prend
telle une telle résonance et une
résonance tirait qui dépasse le cadre
des frontières de l'amérique
et bien déjà pour l'amérique les kennedy
mais c'est vrai pour le monde entier les
kennedy était plus grand que nature
c'était une très grande famille qui fait
atteint des sommets dans la vie
politique et qui a subi un sort tout à
fait atroce on connaît peu de on peut
pas imaginer vraiment une famille qui
est qu'ils soient tellement punissent
elle tellement poursuivi par un parent
la destinée est alors d'après après john
assassiné
robert tous les autres dans la famille
la tragédie autour de ted kennedy
c'est une série de catastrophes est
alors pour une famille qui avait fait
tant de choses ce qui était tellement
aller monté tellement haut tout la
définition du héros tragique c'est
quelqu'un qui monte très haut et qui
tombe très bas et bien c'est vraiment là
la tragédie dans un sens où je dirais
que sophocle aurait du mal à l'imaginer
mais une famille qui à chaque fois ci a
su se relever après après chanel a
toujours su se relever c'est une famille
qui a des ressources intérieures
étonnante et après après chaque tragédie
les autres membres se sont ralliés on
continue et on continuait d'ailleurs
suivre une carrière politique l'avis
officiel
les neveux les fois les frères les
soeurs sont tous très actifs
vous parlez politique vous avez vous
même suivi et participer de façon assez
active à la campagne électorale et de
jon kelly biais de et de robert kennedy
façon très modeste mais c'était pour moi
des deux personnalités politiques pour
lesquels on pouvait vraiment s'investir
parce que et je croyais en eux ils
avaient il avait une intelligence
politique et une humanité qui m'avait
profondément touché il ya dans ce que ce
qui m'a amené à faire des quelques
discours politique probert surtout qui
était qui aurait été un grand président
l'on peut être erronée de l'histoire
jane kennedy n'a pas fait de politique
peut-être parce que la famille voulait
le protéger
sans doute sans doute parce que tous les
canadiens ont ça dans ce sens il
j'imagine que john john aurait bien aimé
faire ça mais dans un pays on assassine
un peu trop facilement les présidents je
pense que à voir un autre kennedy à la
présidence ça aurait été trop fort pour
quelques fous quelque part pour vouloir
le descendre alors c'est un effet très
ironique que pour le protéger de ça il a
fait autre chose et voilà que peut-être
j'espère que nous mais que peut-être il
aura disparu le portrait de john kennedy
un portrait parfois assez mitigées avec
l'image du séducteur du golden boy
gollnisch de réussite et de la séduction
oui golden boy certainement il lille il
aurait pu faire n'importe quoi il aurait
toujours été un golden boy
vu la halle ses débuts triste mais mais
enfin l'amérique n'oubliera jamais le
petit john giorno cercueil de son père
il aurait toujours été ça mais il a fait
une carrière dans le temps dans les
médias intelligente qui là qu'il a fait
lui même
séducteur vont je ne sais pas c'est un
c'est un homme qui a eu qui a vécu sa
vie je ne pense pas que ce soit un
séducteur plus grand que les autres
merci thème michel d'abord répondu à une
question bercy toujours aux états unis
et non loin de la baie de longue haleine
dès la 3 ans jour pour jour le boeing de
la tbw a explosé peu après son décollage
aujourd'hui un document accablant publié
par nos confrères le parisien semble
démontrer que les réservoirs de ces
appareils étaient potentiellement
dangereux et ce depuis les années 70
mais leurs modifications auraient
entraîné des dépenses trop excessive
voire déraisonnables aux yeux de la
compagnie c'est un constat difficile à
accepter notamment par les familles des
victimes patrick fandio fabrice causse
c'est un anniversaire douloureux pour
lequel ils se retrouvent dans cet hôtel
parisien
ils ont perdu un frère un fils une mère
dont l'explosion du vol twh en leur
souvenir
ils font le point tous les 17 juillet
trois ans déjà un mystère qui demeure
aucune explication officielle mais une
conviction chez les enquêteurs
celle de la défaillance technique plus
précisément celle du réservoir central
qui aurait explosé
si l'on en croit le parisien boeing
connaissait dès 1977 les problèmes de
fonctionnement des réservoirs
le constructeur aurait pu prendre des
mesures pour les isolés ou les sécuriser
davantage ce qu'il a refusé de faire
d'après le document publié par le
quotidien un ingénieur de la firme écrit
outre leur efficacité discutable
ces mesures entraîneraient des surcoûts
déraisonnable temps financé
qu'énergétique pour les compagnies
aériennes et les passagers
nous ne pensons pas que ces mesures se
justifie au vu du nombre d'accidents
enregistrés pour les familles des
victimes
voilà bien la preuve du cynisme du
constructeur la preuve qu'il a plus de
responsabilités qui ne veut l'admettre
après cet accident qui est en fait le 20
6e des séries
je n'ai pas les premiers évidemment les
autorités américaines ont fait des
efforts pour modifier la sécurité de ces
appareils mais ils sont assez journée
pas ils sont pas vraiment aboutie à
résoudre les problèmes les pressions les
pressions des sociétés is going sont
trop fortes
boeing aurait-il pu mettre en sécurité
tous ces réservoirs certains experts en
doutent
l'explosion peut survenir sur tous les
modèles il suffit que ces trois facteurs
se combinent que de l'oxygène soient
mélangées aux vapeurs de kérosène dans
le réservoir est vide que la température
soit anormalement élevées et qu'il y ait
un court-circuit sur le boeing 747
ces trois facteurs sont réunis
suffisamment souvent pour
qu'effectivement ce soir risque
supplémentaire mais il n'est pas à
exclure que ça se produise sur d'autres
types d'avions très attendu le rapport
définitif sur l'explosion tardent à être
publiés il devrait l'être à la fin de
l'année de quoi alimenter encore la
controverse pour savoir qui est
responsable de la mort de 230 personnes
au large de new york au kosovo bernard
kouchner a entrepris une tournée sur le
terrain cet après midi le nouvel
administrateur de l'onu s'est rendue à
mitrovica dans ce secteur sous contrôle
des forces françaises
là où l'affrontement entre les deux
communautés serbe et albanaise était
symbolisée ces dernières semaines par un
pont qui coupe la ville en deux un pont
qui retrouve désormais une certaine
activité un signe positif pour bernard
kouchner escalade militaire la chine
multiplie les exercices de mobilisation
et à décréter l'état d'alerté dans le
sud du pays dans le détroit de taiwan en
question la volonté indépendantistes de
taiwan que récuse les autorités
chinoises jérôme benest perplexe hier à
la bourse de hong kong devant la chute
la plus vertigineuse depuis neuf ans les
actions plonger à hong kong
quand la fièvre monte en mer de chine
l'un des points les plus instables du
monde avec la question récurrente de
taiwan pékin considère depuis 50 ans
l'île nationaliste comme une province
rebelle
mais le président taïwanais ne l'entend
toujours pas de cette oreille
quai au queen et aux relations avec
pékin sont des relations d'état à état
hostile prétendre il y a une semaine
résultat le ton monte à pékin qui
réaffirme que taiwan fait partie
intégrante de la chine le ministre
chinois de la défense agite encore une
fois la menace d'une intervention
militaire
et pour mettre les points sur les i
ordonne à ses troupes l'état d' alerte à
nankin est à canton selon un journal de
hong kong 10 bâtiments de guerre chinois
seraient en manoeuvre au nord du détroit
de taiwan dans l'île les exercices de
défense contre une éventuelle attaque
chinoises sont permanents les insulaires
ne veulent pas du principe que pékin
applique à hong kong
un pays deux systèmes le programme de
visite bilatérale initié il ya un an
semble aujourd'hui compromise
parallèlement aux manoeuvres militaires
les grands conflits internationaux se
joue désormais grâce à la stratégie de
l'espionnage informatique les réseaux de
renseignement sont aujourd'hui
indispensables pour gagner ces nouvelles
batailles l'exemple de la nsa aux etats
unis une multinationale du secret que
nous dévoile hervé brusini et philippe
deslandes
l'histoire commence souvent comme ça on
se connecte à internet
et puis on peut être espionnés par cette
grande maison
la nsa agence nationale de la sécurité
à deux pas de washington c'est la plus
grande centrale américaine de
renseignement budget 24 milliards de
francs plus de 200 mille employés sur la
planète
le royaume du secret absolu ces
installations ont été filmées
clandestinement
grâce à des coupoles d'interception
situés sur les cinq continents l'année
s'enregistrent téléphone fax et messages
électroniques du monde
ce lieu ne figure sur aucune carte à 280
km à l'ouest de londres
il appartient aussi à la nsa des balles
de golf des radôme 20 mètres de diamètre
elle abrite les coupoles qui écoute la
planète une armada qui appartient au
projet 415 également appelé système
échelon toute information utile pour une
exploitation politique ou économique est
envoyé à washington
le parlement européen s'est fortement
ému de cet espionnage d'état
il révèle l'existence d'une guerre
presque inconnu la guerre de
l'information et demain midi le magazine
géo police de claude sérillon sera
consacrée aux cyber conflit en corse
après l'audition très médiatique du
témoin de matignon crédit de valter
c'était au tour d'alain christnacht
conseiller pour les affaires intérieures
du premier ministre d'être entendu dans
la plus grande discrétion jeudi dernier
à ajaccio il a été notamment interrogés
sur un coup de téléphone donné par
bernard bonnet à matignon quelques
heures après l'incendié de la paillote
chez francis quelques heures avant en
fait lincendie de la paillote chez
francis avec cette période de vacances
se multiplient sur le marché de l'emploi
les stages d'été chaque année près d'un
million et demi d'élèves et d'étudiants
effectué cette formation qui est aussi
un travail
pour beaucoup ce qui ne devrait être
qu'une parenthèse se transforment en
véritables emplois non rémunéré
sébastien leguay alain look at you en
entreprise version bidon
quand la formation se limite à manipuler
deux ou trois machines
certes complet
antoine lui fait un vrai travail dans
cette agence de communication étudiant
il est stagiaire à mi temps l'après-midi
pour 1000 francs par mois pendant six
mois une ligne de plus sur son cv quand
il calcule le temps passé dans les
stages peu ou pas rémunéré ça commence à
faire beaucoup
oh j'ai dû faire deux ans et demi c'est
long c'est oui c'est mais il faut enfin
je me pense qu'il faut il faut en
profiter tant qu on est étudiant en
faire le maximum par le maximum
d'expérience et voir le maximum de
choses et ensuite il faut savoir
s'arrêter
plus facile à dire qu'à faire car dans
les journaux sur internet de nombreuses
offres s'adressent à ceux qui ont fini
leurs études
l'entreprise prend alors à sa charge la
couverture sociale en lieu et place de
l'université
conséquence l'indemnité est plus faible
encore et donc il faut qu'elle reste
dans sa times ps de paris des jeunes se
réunissent tous les jours pour
s'entraîner dans leur recherche d'emploi
pour eux accepté un stage n'est pas une
démarche positive s'est passé parce que
c'est se mettre encore en position de
demandeur de personnes qui m'ont dit qui
a peur de déranger l'entreprise
moi j'ai un chat un âge où je vais
m'installer dans la vie quand même je ne
pas rester un pseudo des étudiants
pendant encore deux ans pas vous avez
quel âge j'ai 26 ans maintenant à la fin
du deuxième cycle deux tiers des
étudiants ou un stage à leur actif ils
ne sont indemnisés que dans 10 % des cas
autour de 2000 francs pour empêcher les
entreprises de contourner le droit du
travail le syndicat unef id soit
réglementé les stages on dit tout
travail mérite salaire dans le stage et
une peine de travail
il ya une part de formation mais aussi
une part de travail qui doit être payé
donc c'est normal qu'en fonction du
niveau de qualification
il y est de ce point de vue là une
correspondance mais les syndicats de
chefs d'entreprise comme le medef
n'entendent pas signer la charte que
leur soumet l'unef id le contenu la
durée et l'indemnisation des stages
reste définie au cas par cas
toute la ville de rouen se prépare ses
dernières heures à la grande parade
nautique l'armada du siècle va descendre
la scène demain défilé spectacle qui
devrait dès l'aube donné lieu à
l'amarrage de dizaines de vieux
gréements les uns derrière les autres
les amateurs se pressaient sur les quais
pour ce dernier jour de visite
thierry curtet olivier robert grandeur
et décadence d'un empire si le
majestueux personnel c'est le plus grand
voilier ici à rouen avec ses 110 m ces
ex soviétique devenu marin ukrainien en
sont réduits à vendre uniformes
médailles ou verroterie pour participer
à la fête
leur paiement par mois et treize
premières nations sont francs et a
presque la même été manquée en un mois 2
sergueï est organisée note aux poupées
russes
c'est un vieux loup de mer de ces
rassemblements maritimes il y a
longtemps qu'il a liquidé son stock de
pièces authentiques son chiffre
d'affaires il nous l'a confié est assez
exceptionnel à ses yeux il faut dire
qu'encore aujourd'hui les quais étaient
bondés surtout les navires le compte le
plan de la jeanne d'arc est plus modeste
c'est un mille visiteurs par jour les
obligations officielles ont restreint
ses heures d'ouverture alors on attend
longtemps pour la visite vous attendez
une heure et quart on peut pas dire que
ce soit complètement détendant nous
sommes de service de jour et de me
surprend mais c'est aussi notre rôle
donc c'est vrai que tout sauf fatigué
c'est vrai que de temps en temps on
aimerait bien sortir et profiter de
faire la traite avec m avec nos
camarades des autres marines le micro
refermer la plupart des marins l'avouent
la foule si bien mais c'est 1 8 million
de spectateurs si beaucoup vraiment
alors tous attendent demain la descente
de la scène l'air du grand large
quand se retrouver entre m'a enfin le
tour de france sous la canicule avec
cette 13e étape de quelques 236 km la
plus longue du tour mais aussi la plus
chaude apparemment puisque la
température atteint plus de 40 degrés à
l'ombre florent gautreau philippe
deslandes loup soleil leur est tombé sur
la tête sans prévenir après quinze jours
plus tôt tempéré le tour a retrouvé des
ingrédients qui nourrissent sa légende
la chaleur qui déforme le visage et la
sueur qui marque les corps de son
empreinte grâce 40 degrés à l'ombre
d'albi le goudron qui font sur les
chaussées du tarn
le jury des commissaires a décidé de se
montrer généreux les ravitaillements en
eau ont été autorisés jusqu'à 15
kilomètres de l'arrivée contre 50 km en
temps normal
immédiatement le ballet des porteurs
d'eau a commencé l'équipe est chargée de
la corvée vient chercher les bidons à
l'arrière pour les redistribuer à ses
coéquipiers
l'eau est un carburant indispensable en
1983 le hollandais vanderpool avait
battu un record
un jour de grosse chaleur
ce jour là avait perdu 6 kilos donc
qu'il avait dû voir autant de la sono et
x mais pas beaucoup et donc on peut
boire on s'asperge beaucoup évidemment
il faut surtout pas se draper
il faut croire que commesso srt ligny et
elle est moins déshydraté aujourd'hui
les deux italiens ont faussé compagnie à
leurs 13 compagnons d'échappée dans la
dernière côte de l'étape et poursuivants
ne parviennent pas à s'entendre les deux
fuyards vont en profiter
à l'arrivée le champion d'italie
salvatore commesso l'emporter au sprint
devant certaines y lance armstrong
termine tranquillement avec le peloton à
plus de 22 minutes du vainqueur
même par forte chaleur le maillot jaune
c'est faire preuve de sang froid
revenons à présent sur l'abandon hier de
christophe bass ans qui a nerveusement
craquer celui qui symbolise le monsieur
propre du cyclisme connu pour ses
déclarations anti dopage a donc jeté
l'épongé
aujourd'hui il a décidé de s'expliquer
pour lui sur le tour
rien n'a changé c'est toujours la loi du
silence muriel la saga david bres je
regrette pas de sens et j'ai pas
regretter je pouvais faire autrement
donc quand yann daniel que j'ai pris la
décision de partir parce que j'avais
plus envie de continuer cette fois ci je
pouvais plus continuer et le nuage qui
connaît heureusement je pouvais plus les
nerfs ont craqué mais le sourire est
revenu dans un hôtel de pau où il avait
rejoint sa compagne daisy hier
christophe bassons affichettes encore ce
matin le visage marqué d'un homme qui
vient d'affronter une longue épreuve le
jeune coureur semble assumer sereinement
sa décision et ne désarme toujours pas
dans son combat anti dopage
si une telle domination de la part
d'armstrong et de quelques autres
coureurs c'est pas pour rien c'est que
tout simplement c'est pas eu en plus
vite c'est que beaucoup ont régressé en
particulier chez les français ils sont
passés à l'étagé en dessous
avant j'étais un parmi quelques autres
simplement entre l'activité donc se
passer complètement inaperçue
colin 3 ans je voulais pas dénoncé alors
pour son premier tour de france celui
que l'on surnomme babass était plein
d'illusions il pensait qu'il serait
supporté dans ses propos par d'autres
pouvoir après onze jours de course
sa seule parole n'aura pas eu raison de
l' omerta sur le dopage ce moment-là
rester dans un milieu où on se tait et
ce tout le monde donne son avis mais
personne n'en parle
moi je suis là le milieu cycliste et
donc à le vivre je veux le vivre dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
essayer de tout faire pour pourrait
surtout avoir la conscience tranquille
en particulier pour pour pour l'avenir
un avenir qu'il ne partagera peut-être
plus avec son équipe la française des
jeux
d'autres formations lui ont déjà fait
des propositions sérieuses affirme-t-il
le coureur pourra y réfléchir le temps
des vacances des vacances plus longues
que prévu
tennis à pau l'équipe de france a
remporté le double se plaçant ainsi
avantageusement dans le quart de finale
de la coupe davis
christelle bertrand maryse richard
l'équipe de france a doublé la mise
olivier delaitre et fabrice santoro
forment une des meilleures équipes de
double du monde et il fallait au moins
ça pour battre les brésiliens
les français ont eu besoin d'un set pour
prendre les choses en main santoro y
deux lettres ont mis au point en
cachette une botte secrète le langage la
table français espagnol portugais on
comprend donc que je bats qui fâchent on
va faire
est ce qu'on fait les français ont pris
de vitesse les brésiliens
surpris que muretaine et on signe ce
s'en sont aussi pris à l'arbitrage très
énervé les deux hommes sont un peu
décontenancé ils n'auront pas le dernier
mot
santoro y de lettres se connaissent bien
ils ont les automatismes du double
former une bonne équipe c'est souvent
une question victims les français
s'imposent 7 6 6 4 6 4
olivier delaitre de retour qu'il n'a pas
joué en coupe davis depuis 1995 alors
avant de rejoindre b j apprends deux ans
c'est super serré montrèrent un souvenir
fabuleux
l'équipe de france est encore debout
elle mène 2.1 demain pour conclure
forget compte surtout sur pioline et sur
sa bonne étoile
l'événement cinématographique aux états
unis avec la sortie très attendue du
dernier film de stanley kubrick quelques
semaines après le décès du réalisateur
l'accueil très mitigé du public et de la
critique pour eyes wide shut interprété
par nicole kidman et tom cruise le film
devrait sortir en septembre en france
en avant première les impressions des
premiers spectateurs daniel wolfromm
l'affiché est prometteuse
le film attendu la séance s'annonçait
chaude n'avait-on pas vu depuis la mort
de stanley kubrick ces bands annonça
qu'il chante comme le thème du film
lui-même un couple marié à la ville
comme à l'écran
nicole kidman tom cruise est un week-end
de cesse de remise en cause et de
déchets en a marre bref le dernier film
de kubrick avait à l'image de son oeuvre
une réputation sulfureuse première
réaction hier plutôt la douche froide
est ce film je pense qu'il est très
faible je crois qu'il n'y a pas de fil
conducteur c'est vraiment bien différent
de ce que je pensais et pourtant j'ai
bien aimé tous les autres films de
kubrick
c'est intéressant mais je pense que ce
surévalué survendu c'était lent ennuyeux
tout simplement creux économisez votre
argent ni à l'épinglé et pourtant le
film a séduit le new york times et la
chaîne de télé bissy qui voit le travail
d'un maître du cinéma ce spectateur
aquis lui aussi c'était très différent
de sa part
c'était vraiment très bien moi j'ai
adoré mais le public européen lui est
différent des américains et peut
accueillir autrement la dernière oeuvre
de stanley kubrick le début des
collections haute couture l'hiver en
plein été sur les podiums aujourd'hui
versace une collection plus
qu'audacieuse et puis 30 le classicisme
de raffinement de bon aloi il colle
lecornu langlois bernard connor
précieuses minutes de repos dernière
rectification quelques recommandations
il faudrait l'emmener en blouse et lui
faire faire le parcours va ça et c'est
parti pour un défilé de 50 modèles plein
de sensualité de volupté grand retour de
la fourrure en étole en bordure de
décolleté ou en manchon qu'il peut faire
office de sac
parfois c'est juste un ruban de vison
sur une longue robe en tulle et velours
l'éventail est une valeur sûre en
complément d'une robe perlé soulignait
d'un dégradé de rose pinte
lander des broderies et des plumes
d'autruche
le t-shirt rebrodé de perles peut se
porter sous une veste sous un kimono en
velours vénitien pain mode pour grande
voyageuse d'un siècle à l'autre même
opulence et même élégance dans un tout
autre style tout et ce tracé décidé
voici les amazones de versace à demi
dénudées des gans et des nervures
adoucissent le côté cosmopolite les
découpes sont audacieuses war
vertigineuse et les asymétries fort bien
géré et pailleté
ces modèles c'est certain ne sont pas
faits pour les timorés mais pour des
femmes provocante qui n'ont peur de rien
et surtout pas d'entrer dans le nouveau
millénaire
kuljic d'or bardet de signes extérieurs
d'insolente conquête
dans le finistère l'un des rares
concerts du groupe britannique massive
attack qui s'est produit hier soir sur
la scène du festival des vieilles
charrues
l'an dernier plus de cent mille
spectateurs pour une manifestation qui
mélange tous les registres père emmanuel
luneau olivier julien soleil sable
musique et luttent pour automne
voilà quelques-uns des ingrédients du
festival des vieilles charrues bon je
croyais que c b peace and love ce
week-end ça montre un peu les traditions
jean faut savoir faire évoluer ses
traditions et en allemand une diversité
de deux concerts et musique comme ça ici
quoi faire connaître la culture bretonne
et s'ouvrir à toutes les musiques
tel est le pari de ce jeune festival en
huit ans et grâce à celui de bouche à
oreille c'est réunion a pris très vite
une ampleur nationale et européenne
l'année dernière elle attiré à elle
cent mille spectateurs et devenait le
rendez vous de l'été en bretagne ça
devient un peu un rituel quoi est bon ce
parent peut vraiment comprendre et
tenter enfin de quoi manger un peu puis
c'est tout
on les organisateurs la mode de la
bretagne est une aubaine surtout qu'à
ses débuts les vieilles charrues c'était
presque une boutade où on a essayé de
faire un clin d'oeil à brest 4 radio
c'était une grande fête maritime qui se
déroulait dans la cité du ponant
puis nous on a eu envie ici de faire une
grande fête aussi avec 500 personnes le
s p 500 1000 et contre les vieux
gréements mais il ya eu les les geishas
rue en fait de vieilles charrues ce sont
les missiles du groupe anglais massive
attack qui ont hier soir mis le feu au
festival devant plus de 30000
spectateurs
du classement provisoire ces clichés en
france vous voulez la qualité c'est ce
qu'on a apporté
on a joué une fois paris où nous a jeté
des bouteilles alors maintenant on donne
le meilleur de ce qu'on a fait
massive attack sera suivi ce soir par
stéphane richard et triaud demain par
ben harper et jacques higelin de quoi
conforter la réputation d'un festival
désormais incontournable
avant de refermer ce journal je vous
propose de faire le point sur la
disparition de la viande de john kennedy
le fils du président assassiné les
dernières informations avec hervé
brusini il y à quelques minutes une
chaîne locale reprise partielle annoncé
qu'un bagage portant le nom de la femme
de john fitzgerald kennedy junior avait
été retrouvé on a même parlé dur ou
d'avion de débris divers
c'est pour l'heure toutes ces
informations ne sont pas encore
confirmés la plupart des membres de la
famille kennedy réunis sur l'île de
martha's vineyard site ici que devait
arriver l'avion de john-john et l'a fait
pour le mariage de rory kennedy s'est
transformé en une cruelle attentes
ici on garde encore l'espoir
on voudrait tant que tout finisse bien
il y avait beaucoup de gens ce matin
nous attendions ensemble les dernières
nouvelles mais à cette heure ci je suis
incapable de changer on cherche des
recherches qui se poursuivent elles sont
conduites par les garde-côtes et l'armée
de l'air c'est donc la fin de ce journal
tout de suite après la météo patrice
drevet 20h50 fort boyard de ma midi
géopolis représentée par claude sérillon
j'aurais plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 13h excellente fin de soirée
sur france 2